Mr Speaker I don't want to finish this
session without asking about the covert
disclosures in today's Daily Telegraph
now we don't know the truth of what
happened yet there are too many messages
and too many unknowns open families
across the country families across the
country will look at this and the site
of politicians writing books portraying
themselves as heroes or selectively
leaking messages will be insulting a
ghoulish spectacle for them
the heart of this is every family who
made enormous sacrifices for the good of
the country or who tragically lost loved
ones
country deserves better the covered
inquiry has already cost the taxpayer 85
million pounds and hasn't heard from a
single government Minister yet so can
the Prime Minister assure the house no
more delays that the inquiry will have
whatever support it needs to report by
the end of this year
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the last couple of years were
an incredibly difficult line for
everyone involved in the Health Service
and I pay tribute to all their hard work
and I know the house will join me in
that regard and now rather than comment
on piecemeal bits of information I'm
sure the honorable General agree with me
the right way for these things to be
looked at is the covert inquiry that's
why we've established the covert inquiry
and he will know he will know as I have
he has mentioned it one or two times
before that he was a lawyer in a
previous life that there is a proper
process to these things it is an
independent inquiry it has the resources
it needs it has the powers it needs and
what we should all do in this house is
let them get on and do their job